thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an
inventive wild ride with Stevo this
week's guest is a fascinating guy if you
have not heard of Carter share let me
tell you he is like a modern day Tony
Stark Iron Man he's a genius an inventor
an engineer and a wildly successful
YouTuber by God the kid is Rich and on
this episode I get kind of bent out of
shape okay I throw a serious temper
tantrum and my initial thought was to
save myself from the embarrassment by
editing it out of the episode but then I
thought you know what I'm a I'm an
accountable kind of guy I like to be
held accountable for my actions so we
left it in boy do I lose my cookies on
this episode but fortunately this
episode is brought to you by nordvpn I
gotta say that I've been traveling
around the world and enjoying the hell
of international Netflix when I'm
International I'm watching American
Netflix Hulu like my fights I do not
miss my UFC fights now how is this all
possible because of
nordvpn not only does nordvpn give you
your own safe virtual encrypted Network
so that you don't have like viruses
coming in you don't have people snooping
around and stealing your information you
just create your own IP address by
clicking whatever country you want to uh
be in and man you all of the content of
the world opens up to you and you're a
lot safer too I love my VPN subscription
and you can get a huge deal on yours
plus four months free if you go to
nordvpn.com
Stevo and with nord's 30-day money-back
risk-free trial period there's no reason
not to do this again they're going to
give you a huge discount on your
subscription plus four additional months
free if you go to nordvpn.com
Stevo so jump on it and let's get into
it
ladies and gentlemen Carter sharer yo
all right yeah dude gotta make sure that
mic's ready
um we we have a secret relationship the
the world is not aware of super secret
there's some uh a lot of people might
think oh this is a a counter-intuitive
odd pairing
but we've actually got a project we're
working on together a little bit of
History yeah it um would behoove us to
not draw too much attention to the
project because it remains to be seen
whether it will actually make it to the
light of day but it's been exciting
working with you it's been wild yeah
yeah I'm excited and in the interest of
not
um alienating or offending the listeners
we can uh probably be a little bit big
that
um Carter's expertise your your
expertise is uh an inventor an engineer
a a builder a a doer of cool things
coupled with my reputation for being
sort of wild and crazy can can a little
bit inform like what we might be doing
together in the vein of developing a
television series yeah I think uh yeah
unlikely friends that have different
kind of backgrounds and skill sets put
together to make something interesting
right to build cool ass crazy [ __ ] like
not to alienate more people the name of
the show is called
right but uh man dude was I impressed to
uh film the uh sort of pilot so to speak
at your
um new property in North Carolina to
find that it's just littered with luxury
cars and and uh a mansion and just like
I mean it's evident that they're doing
very well for yourself with your YouTube
career you have a mansion a mansion yeah
there is no other word for the home on
this 40-acre property 110 110
yeah there is no other word for that
home than a mansion yeah to be fair so
um yeah it's cool man it's really uh
really impressive to see you go and uh
to see the things that you've done
um
like I wonder how many different for
people who maybe are tuning into the
wild ride podcast and they don't know as
much about you let's get some background
from for sure yeah a lot of background
well I want to say that also work with
this project too it's pretty cool to
work with you yeah well thank you man I
appreciate that a lot growing up
watching jackass and stuff I was
probably in like middle school or
something it just it was yeah I
definitely grew up like seeing you never
thought I would get into entertainment
or like YouTube which is what I do now
and then having the chance to meet with
you and then some of the podcasts it's a
pretty cool experience I would say yeah
remember when we were shooting at your
compound we were talking about the
podcast you said that you were thinking
about starting one yeah I'm still kind
of thinking about it just need the
bandwidth and the setup you know you got
to build like a studio out like this so
right a little bit of prep work but yeah
I would encourage you to do so
um see so uh more more in the way of
background you um how old are you now
um 28 28 wow I would even guess younger
but uh but you went to University with
a focus on engineering is that right
yeah so it got started my background at
College I went to uh Carnegie Mellon
University and then I did um started at
physics and then switched over to
Computer Engineering and Robotics
um and then after that I went to
University of Pennsylvania to work on
self-driving cars
so driving cars man is that something
that's going to happen I feel like it's
a a black eye for Elon Musk like all of
the the promising about like the
self-driving and all it's just like it's
it's certainly not happened on the
timeline that he seems to have promised
and it doesn't seem like is it ever
going to happen I think so I don't think
it's I don't think we're that far away
from it and um it's just the technology
hasn't caught up to the data or
something no and they're just not
putting it out we've the school that I
went to back Carnegie Mellon made a
minivan like an old retro like purple
minivan Drive the entire country down
and back without having to ever touch
the steering wheel in like 1989 wow you
know so uh you know that's when
computers were the size of like
microwaves and stuff but
it's also fair to say that given the
litigious lawsuit friendly Society yeah
uh that you can't go and send people in
cars without drivers and then expect not
to get your ass screwed off if anything
goes wrong yeah definitely easing into
it but uh Ford just came out with
something called Blue cruise and it's
full hands-off driving so you like push
a button you take your feet off the
pedals hands off the steering wheel you
just sit there and it'll drive for you
are you familiar with like Teslas yeah I
mean is it better technology than the
Teslas or is it um similar because with
the Tesla you have to kind of jolt the
steering wheel yeah it's no it's better
for sure because uh so Liz has a Tesla
Model X it's better than Tesla yeah any
type of It kind of it drives like a
computer whereas um
the ones for like Ford and I haven't
tried the ones like Chevy and stuff but
they drive more like a human like it's
like gentle like the Tesla will like
speed up into a stop sign and then slam
the brakes it sees it like it's just
doesn't really work that well in my
opinion the Elon Musk said if you're if
you're standing by a on the sidewalk and
you have a shirt that has a stop sign on
it it'll pick up the stop sign and stop
the car
which is kind of interesting that's
really funny I'm actually not heard that
but yeah but that uh yeah that's
interesting and then and then also
Ford's taking the model of
um Tesla where they're getting rid of
their car dealerships where you just go
in and you buy the cars now that's cool
and I thought that was pretty
interesting yeah but with the whole uh
being here you say that you're a Tesla
driver yeah and I ordered one but I
don't have it yet
yeah I'll never go back to another car
you like them unless it's like I want to
get a vintage like 1980 like VW bus or
something like that yeah but I but I
like the idea of um
it's getting a little warm in here huh
[ __ ] warm in here if any dude it was
working
all right well I turned on I opened up
the door it's [ __ ] not okay to not
have AC and and maybe just buy a [ __ ]
new one but just [ __ ] fix it
the Air's coming in now there we go
please just kind of stand by
the last thing I want to be doing is
talking about air conditioning during a
podcast but there you go we did please
don't make me have to talk about air
conditioning anymore
foreign
if there's any air conditioning sponsors
yeah I mean whatever
um so the engineering is pretty cool
when you look at something you can you
could take it apart and like see how it
works that's like pretty much the gist
of what an engineer does yeah from a
high level I would say so yeah and
that's how you're able to like put a
Lambo with an RC car controller like you
can cut it was a Mini Cooper right we
did a PT Cruiser PT Cruiser yeah and
that yeah we'll give you the idea to do
that like how do you start figuring that
out and connecting it to a controller
minus the Bluetooth I mean dude it was
so cool man and then you had already
made YouTube videos out of this
full-size yeah remote control car yeah
yeah like growing up and watching
Mythbusters they would do like crazy
stuff with like uh the remote control
car they did it back in the day too and
they would always go off and crash and
stuff but then yeah once I moved out and
we were like all right we have another
trip planned we're going out to North
Carolina we have the space like let's go
buy like a cheap car and make it
self-driving so basically you just need
to have the uh remote control remote
controller yeah so you just have to turn
the wheel and then push two pedals
that's all that's all you need right so
we just came up with two Motors one that
would push the gas and wanted to push
the brake you know if you push like up
on this the joystick it would just kind
of go down and lift up and down right so
you put an actuator for each pedal and
then one for the steering wheel and we
built the whole thing in probably three
hours just put it all together really
yeah dude it was pretty epic dude you
got the the
like
the whole mechanics of like the pedals
actually being pushed by like uh you
know mechanism like
the steering wheel is actually being
turned by like all these this robotics
is probably the word for it right yeah
we just did it with all off the shelf
super cheap I think it was probably the
cheapest self-driving car ever built at
least that we could find on the internet
like no one did it simpler and cheaper
than we did yeah do you have any
projects like that ongoing I mean I know
that took you three hours but are there
any like like week-long or lifelong
projects that you're like like a Doc
Brown in the lab yeah constantly working
on that you haven't shown the world yet
um
are we gonna leave
I'm so sorry for that guys it's all good
I swear I think here
and don't [ __ ] leave just make sure
the [ __ ] thing works
I'm turning into Winnebago Man over here
Winnebago Man this [ __ ] guy that just
rages all the time because
yeah even if the doors are open that's
fine but for the love of [ __ ] God
don't go anywhere make sure
I told you I throw an embarrassing
temper tantrum in this episode you could
say I was fuming but that's not always a
bad thing because fume products are like
one of the best ways to help you quit
smoking cigarettes and Vapes what is it
it's this wooden inhaler and you put
into it a core which is infused with
natural oils which have been proven to
help with cravings for nicotine and The
Core is coming all these awesome flavors
cozy chai black pepper lemon berry Bliss
cocoa mint white cranberry and I've got
peppermint in there right now
it's delicious and even though I haven't
had a cigarette in 14 years I'm still
enjoying it and it's perfectly natural
it's there's nothing unhealthy about it
and with smoking and vaping a big part
of the addiction is just this hand to
mouth fidgety busy work and if you've
got this to be doing the little fidgety
busy work of smoking then you're halfway
home and the oils that they use in these
cores are proven to help with craving
scientifically and man do I back this
product because cigarettes Vape it's all
just disgusting it just makes you look
like a loser and fume is here to help
you quit so get 10 off your entire order
by going to
[Music]
breathefume.com that's b-r-e-a-t-h-e
fum.com
Stevo and again you're going to get 10
off your order and please do it because
with the cigarettes and the Vapes it's
just a bad look so again
breathefume.com slash Devo for 10 off
your entire order and let's see how I do
with the rest of this tantrum
like uh whatever it is man like we could
feel it when it's on it's great it's
just not okay to not have AC
all right what where the [ __ ] were we
saying before
because like Paul's gonna be like oh no
leave it in it's great [ __ ] you Paul
yeah we were talking about like uh
anger management stuff
[Laughter]
my dad just had a super stressful day
too on top of it that feels great Vinnie
just keep it like that
ah
seriously
seriously man like walk us back to where
we're we're talking about the world's
cheapest uh RC pretty much the cheap
driving yeah right right right right
yeah so we built that but yeah you know
there's also a little bit of an
interesting story so it's pretty sketchy
I mean it literally is like the cheapest
we built we got the car for like two
grand or 1500 bucks it's like a really
ugly PT Cruiser like red
uh but it drives really good it's like
you know it's a nice car but it's just
nobody it's undesirable so it's cheap so
we started with a cheap car and then we
put cheap electronics in it all off the
shelf all just plug and play like hobby
level stuff that was strong enough to
push and pull on the pedals and stuff
like that uh so yeah I made it so like
the whole build process was just plywood
a couple screws some zip ties you know
whatevers but it worked really well
probably the whole thing was like under
three grand or something wow dude and it
was literally a day we had a we planned
like four days to put it together and we
finished by lunch on the first day how
many views you get on that video
over a few million probably yeah that's
like the norm yeah it's pretty normal
how many subscribers do you have on
YouTube uh I just hit 9 million nine
million dude you're on the on the final
stretch for the diamond plaque yeah I'm
excited never thought I'd get to 10 but
we're right around the corner so anyways
yeah you know driving the car you know
when no one's in it you're away you know
it's like all fun and games I think it
goes fast that goes 100 miles an hour if
you like push on the stick it's like you
know as fast as a regular car
and um but you start to realize it's
sketchy when you start like getting
comfortable with it you start sitting on
the roof with the controller or you know
you're really driving a car yeah we've
established for the listeners that we're
talking about there's an easy boy like
sofa chair mounted on the roof yeah
they're sitting and while you're in
remote control driving it yeah so you're
driving yourself around while you're
sitting on the roof of the car in a lazy
boy yeah with the big old remote control
it's [ __ ] nuts yeah and when we
filmed this pilot I was like introducing
the pilot while sitting in the chair and
they're just driving me around like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like yeah I think we
need there's a big story about this I
really want to tell him this
um
for this yeah so for this this project
we're working on uh part of it was like
let's put a big fat like sofa chair up
there yeah so then someone would sit on
there and ended up being you and then
we're on the ground all safe with uh you
know the controller ripping it in the we
have this hit big 10 acre field so we're
just ripped and we're doing like 40 mile
an hour passes you're right I was never
going 40 miles an hour at least 35 40.
damn I was yeah I got some clips and it
was like I'm looking at like how fast
they're driving the car and I'm like
dude this is so sketchy wow so sketchy I
don't feel like it was ever like
particularly dangerous but I was
strapped in you were focused on the
camera doing your thing you didn't have
a clue and that's why the story is so
funny so yeah we're driving it around my
friends got the controller and we're
doing passes they took it out the night
before and they added a couple extra
safeties one of which was a garage door
opener that when you click the garage
door opener it turns the key off of the
car as like an extra safety and so uh
you know not really tested that much he
took it out the night and kind of ripped
on it it was all good but for you you
know we're going a little bit more a
little bit faster
the show Runners faster hit hard or go
because he's screaming at us and I'm
thinking like I'm like sweating I'm like
seeing this thing and if something
happens there's not a lot of time to
react and mind you too that like while
they're uh you know setting up the car
for me to get on the roof you've got
like the the network legal department
over there like wait no he can't get in
the Kentucky signs this thing and and
like there's all this stuff going on
behind the scenes with with my
entertainment lawyer like signing off on
the the waiver and there's just like a
high stress level thing and I finally
just [ __ ] signed my life away and
then get onto the what I was talking
about so we're doing these passes you're
doing well as you're focused on the
camera I'm sweating watching my friend
drive he's the one that helped me build
it and uh so there's like a couple
problems with it where like if something
like if it loses power gets unplugged
what happens is it doesn't just like
come to a stop it just remembers the
last command so if that's like 50
throttle and straight like it'll just do
that and you won't have any connection
and you'll just be off have and so it's
like sketchy and so we're doing things
and we're doing these passes where
you're going like 40 miles an hour just
ripping by us it's scary and Wendy's
chasing the car yeah
oh my gosh I have all this on camera too
it's on one of my phones somewhere and
so anyways we're going through and we're
doing a we did like a really fast high
speed like straight line and then slam
the brakes and then turn right before
the lake because they're trying to like
goat me in so that like while I'm like
delivering my lines in the chair like
it's supposed to be like look you know I
like to make it funny and and you're
just saying your lines you don't even
know how fast you're going oh yeah and
it's like
yeah pretty much and so anyways we're
driving it and there's like three sides
are all trees you're gonna hit big trees
if you were to go off bounds that way or
go into the lake after a big hill and uh
so yeah we did a really fast pass and
slammed the brakes and then turned and
then as we came back we did like a kind
of like another turn and then the car
just lost power and so it's spinning in
a circle at maybe 10 15 miles an hour
and just going like this and we're doing
the controllers we're going through the
safety protocol nothing's working and so
you know you're still doing lines you're
just going to like a big circle like
this just around and around with your
feet hanging off the side and I'm like
we're just lucky that the wheels
returned otherwise we would have been
into a tree and so we shout to Bob who's
you know an old dude they were like you
know because he was the stunt
coordinator guy the stunt coordinator he
had the final safety which is that
garage door opener that we put in the
night before and so he you know we're
shouting to him and he's like 30 feet
behind us in conversation and he like
looks up pulls it out of his pocket you
know Knight pulls the antenna and then
hits the button and then kills the
switch and then it comes to a stop and
you're like oh I guess we're done and
you hop off and I'm thinking like dude
if those Wheels were in a straight line
you would have been into a tree yeah and
yeah
if it was uh set at like 50 miles an
hour instead of 15. yeah yeah exactly so
the first pass right before it came
unplugged was like 40 miles an hour
straight for her Steep Hill to the lake
and I'm like I don't know if you're
walking away from that and that was
really scary so luckily so we tell that
story from time to time and it's
something that was so stressful but like
it went so wrong and right at the same
time I mean it was all good it made for
great footage nobody even knew anything
it wrong and meanwhile me and my two
friends who built the thing are sitting
there sweating like dude we almost
killed him yeah [ __ ] dude if your
entertainment lawyer is listening to
this right now he's like see I told you
always wait right
um the uh in my heart I feel that if it
was going like 50 miles an hour towards
a tree that uh it might just be dope
footage and I would have like I would
have like Dove off and jumped off of it
you know and like tuck and roll or
something
I mean I don't know
he said we were going 30 miles an hour
35. so fast yeah and that's where we
were going then then that's what it
could have been yeah you jumped out how
fast was the plane going when you jumped
out of it 40 miles easy geez oh that's
I thought it'd be going way faster I
know it was just one of these little
water world like uh sea glider aircraft
yeah
yeah [ __ ] man so do you have any like we
were talking about earlier the projects
that you're working on that like that
haunt you at night to go to sleep but
you're constantly working on there's
actually one and I filmed it yesterday
uh before I flew out here and then did
you finish it yeah how long did it take
you to do so I I kind of had a shortcut
on this one so the idea was to like get
a car
waterproof it all like the engine and
everything so you can drive it
underwater wearing a scuba tank and
drive under the bottom of a lake
it would have to have a snorkel right
you would need snorkel yeah we need some
kind of like way to get air probably a
snorkel but in a car would do that yeah
like a Land Cruiser with the big L that
comes up like the exhaust yeah and you
know some cars can like take on water a
bit but like I want to go completely
submerged underwater like 10 feet deep
and need like a scuba mask while you're
sitting in the driver's seat breathing
air and driving underwater that's cool
so you filmed that yesterday we filmed
that yesterday wow yeah how long did it
take you to do so someone built this car
already it is actually like an old
military Hummer yeah it's crazy so we
filmed I don't know if the video is live
when we posted so did you just rent the
existing Hummer or you being just like
this [ __ ] obnoxiously wealthy
YouTuber you bought it no it was a zero
dollar budget so my friend that uh that
we met for this project happened to have
this Hummer that he waterproofed okay
and it's got tank treads yeah that's the
greatest thing about Carter not only is
he like just the most fascinating like
tenacious just like unbelievably
creative guy yeah like all of his
buddies are the same way like when we
filmed this project we had his buddy who
was the the Green Goblin in the last
Spider-Man movie because he he built uh
the self-flying machine where he's just
standing on a bunch of like drones
effectively like built together and it's
like a hovercraft he's like got his own
remote control and he's flying around
yeah we're hanging out with him he's
flying around the property on his he's
no big deal yeah the Green Goblin flyer
machine those are his buddies in like
the 20s like mine were like putting
mushrooms in my burrito like
yeah so here's a clip of the Hummer from
yesterday oh wow so we're in here we got
the jet ski in front of us
I'll just show you this
what are you guys looking at for the for
the people listening
so now now what's your upload schedule
like on YouTube are you in a situation
where you filmed this yesterday and it's
already out or like no not quite this
will come out next week okay probably
next Saturday
yeah and I think uh it's very safe to
say that this podcast will have already
whichever would not have yet come out
okay so then it's live on my channel if
you guys want to check it out live on
Carter shares Channel youtube.com
Carter sharer yep
brilliant driving underwater or
something like that I'm dying to know
have you heard anything from the
producers that we filmed that project
with
uh well I saw the
you know the pilot that came out dude I
saw an early cut of it what like when
did you see uh like the I assume it was
like the final yeah
I don't know it's been a while I thought
we would have heard back by now I know
but it took for a little bit indignant
I'm like what like how are you gonna not
tell us what's going on yeah and then I
think my next thought is well I'm thank
God I'm busy enough that I'm not like
sitting by the phone waiting for it to
ring so like it kind of like I'm
grateful that I don't care too much yeah
but it would be nice I feel like it'd be
a nice courtesy if they would reach out
and give us some updates they're
probably listening
yeah yeah come on guys give us a shout
out no worries yeah I mean come on dude
what am I like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh dude like Dave England said on the
jackass thread he goes I must be a
mushroom because they uh [ __ ] keep me
in the dark and keep feeding me [ __ ]
yeah well that's good so what do you
what are you doing out in LA
so I'm here for like
three days three days yep we shot a
Snapchat show this morning cool Liz did
I was just there to help her out uh and
the people that you showed up with those
that's your production crew yeah my
girlfriend Liz and then our uh
videographer yeah so we shot this
morning with the dimelio sisters Charlie
demilio and Dixie and it was like this
whole Snapchat production that was uh
like super early morning but yeah we did
that and then we're doing this yeah she
recorded but this was just like a last
minute thing it was so glad we're doing
it yeah yeah you can't talk about what
you're doing yet can you for the
SnapChat thing I probably can't talk on
it now yeah I'm interested by this
because
um
because uh I've got a Snapchat
programming
deal and it's really just uh an exercise
in and Recycling and repurposing
existing content that I've put on
YouTube okay but you're you're filming
original stuff oh it doesn't live on
YouTube exclusively for Snapchat yeah
well this isn't really my like project
at all this was like a guest for the one
the one of the episodes okay but yeah
it's just huge production it's all put
on by Snapchat dude it's amazing how
Snapchat
has uh endured and survived like you
would think that when Instagram started
doing stories and and Facebook started
doing stories that like their model got
stolen and that like they would become
somehow obsolete but Snapchat is alive
and well
they're putting a lot of money into
stuff I can tell you that much yeah it's
unbelievable but tick tock's kind of
just taking over everything I I know
dude and like how do people have the
time to go bouncing back and forth I
think they start to all the people that
were on Facebook like you know five ten
years ago like my mom's just getting
involved in the Instagram you know and
everybody that's been in Instagram is
going over to tick tock and I feel like
you know there's still some people that
are brand new to Facebook is Facebook
dipping at all and it's uh yeah they are
they lost like 70 of their share that's
why I think they're working on the
metaverse because you gotta what are you
what are you gonna do this is the
metaverse not like somehow like
tied to crypto in some sense right I
think it's the currency that you yeah I
mean you would know more yeah where are
you at with crypto what do you think
about all that I think crypto is good I
don't know a whole lot about like the
future yeah yeah but I think like you're
gonna be able to have like the whole
metaverse is going to be built on I mean
what what's the technology behind the
metaverse it's
blockchain
you're watching something different I
don't know I know there's a lot of like
video games that are coming out that
like incorporate a lot of like different
forms of crypto yeah like people are
making money off video games now with
crypto so like if you win a level you
get money or yeah or like you can buy
like Pokemon cards but like you're
battling each other on or it's like nfts
and stuff like that like you can buy
like a car like in GTA or some game and
then you can rent that car to other
players
which is just crazy I just understand
why that wouldn't be I mean they're
saying the next the next push the uh
crypto is going to be the 12th sector of
the s p 500. i mean I don't even know
but I think I've already decided to let
Paul keep all that in and that to thank
Vinnie for keeping that AC running so
thank you Vinnie dog
you're killing it out there he hasn't
taken he hasn't taken his eyes off that
[ __ ]
I know I got real I mean it got hot in
here real bad
yeah dude I think if anybody was in that
van they would agree it was hot like
real bad but let me tell you about when
it gets hot real good
it's when I take my Bluetooth tablets
baby and what are they well they're
delicious chewable tablets with the same
active ingredient as both Viagra and
Cialis yeah plus they cost only a
fraction of the price and
proven to give you a mean boner that's
what it's all about baby you know yeah
chew your Bluetooth tablets about a half
hour later ready to take your girl to
Bone Town pound town that's right and
that's what happens man when I chew my
Bluetooth tablets I have never let Lux
down I have always gone to war with her
vagina that's right and I love it and it
is so easy to get your Bluetooth tablets
because when you go to bluetooth.com you
can consult with the medical provider
online very quick very easy that takes
care of your prescription and if you use
the promo code Stevo you get an entire
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets
completely for free all you have to pay
is five bucks for shipping now if you've
ever wondered are Bluetooth tablets a
lot of fun I can assure you the answer
is yes I have it ton of fun with them I
love it so I think you're gonna love it
too that's why it's time for you to head
on over to bluechew.com and use the
promo code Stevo for an entire month's
supply of Bluetooth tablets and all you
got to pay is five bucks for shipping
just saying now let's get back to it
real fast real hot I thought I thought
it was just missing me and getting you
guys and like I take my glasses off
because they're fogging up it was so hot
no dude like I I'm gonna give myself a
break for for getting grumpy because it
was that hot and now it feels great
because Vinnie's killing it
yeah how do you like La where are you
from originally I grew up near DC DC
yeah Northern Virginia so not too far
from where Northern Virginia
uh it was called Oakton all right is
that near McLean Virginia it's really
close to Mclean yeah because we saw you
in DC last year at the show right yeah
that's where we met yeah yeah we met at
the show I was
I was actually at my new place in North
Carolina which is only four hours away
so we drove up to that one stayed at my
parents place went into DC yeah you got
to slept over to your parents condo yeah
from your Mansion no my parents have a
house too but what do your parents do
um my dad's a patent attorney I thought
well there you go oh man it has a dream
come true does that not like just fit in
magically is that like did that inform
what the game plan no you came into the
[ __ ] project late and it just so
happened to be that your dad was a
patent attorney yeah when you texted me
that it was about like inventions and
patents and stuff I was like dude this
is like for me dude and that's what got
you into inventing stuff because the
hardest part about inventing is like
patenting your idea yeah like growing up
with my dad I was I think he was
probably a big part of like why I wanted
to like invent or like build or stuff
like that yeah so him being like a you
know an IP lawyer it was definitely kind
of me I guess probably inspired that a
lot yeah yeah that's crazy that's super
cool The Coincidence of that is like
really really like striking like almost
Beyond like
coincidence yeah it was kind of crazy
because we met at DC in that show and
then it was only like a few weeks later
you texted me this thing I think it was
a little more than a few weeks but who
cares I mean it's just it was pretty
good it's unbelievable because these
guys were you know the the people from
this project like oh do you have anybody
in mind I'm like oh well if we're
talking about a show about crazy
inventions and patents and building like
I'm this guy Carter sharer builds all
kinds of [ __ ]
yeah unbelievable
what was your uh
in like an engineer school like your
final project what did you build in
school
you have to build something crazy or
elaborate racist yeah yeah no our school
wasn't set up that way
um but yeah some things that I built in
college
um built like you know lots of little
different robots one was like a little
robot arm that held a pen and it could
draw like pictures and write stuff Jesus
I said that was like you could program
like what it's gonna draw and it draws
it perfect yeah basically so like I
built like a like a paint program on the
computer so you can just you know write
and draw what you want like with the
mouse and then you can click print and
then it'll just the robot will just do
what you did write it on paper but when
you graduated college what would you
want to do I mean I'm sure you didn't
see yourself
doing a YouTube channel no definitely
not YouTube didn't come until a little
bit after but
um yeah in college I was just thinking
I'd probably work at like Uber or Tesla
really something like that [ __ ] man yeah
in college I thought I just thought
maybe I'll just you know be like an
engineer for Tesla yeah and no biggie
yeah
I had no idea that I'd become a global
phenomenon on YouTube where do you
compare yourself uh maybe it's not fair
to frame it like that but uh how much do
you relate or feel like a colleague to
the guy Colin Furs oh yeah dude I used
to watch him a lot that guy is bad ass
yeah he's crazy you guys kind of have
very similar Vibes in the content that
you create is that fair to say
definitely yeah
um my channel hasn't really been all
about like building stuff
um I mean that's kind of like where my
passion and stuff started and early on
my videos would be about trying to build
as much as I could but they just take so
long so I found some easier like some
other avenues to get into like more
challenge based and experienced stuff
but I still do build a lot of stuff
um but yeah you upload like a crazy
volume right yeah it's high volume three
videos a week yeah well I mean when I
first started it was five videos a week
for a year and then it went down to like
three for a while and it's been two a
week for uh the last couple so it's been
yeah I probably put over a thousand
videos like it's a lot yeah tons of
videos it's crazy I know then hence the
[ __ ] the Lamborghini and the the
what's the the really old luxury cars
the Lamborghini Countach okay yep so
crazy how many cars do you have a lot I
don't know a lot yeah I do have a lot
he's got a lot yeah like what do you
mean a lot of 10 50 yeah probably under
50. it's probably like way over 10 ways
just whatever you you like [ __ ] I want
that car you get it or yeah I just got
like like his property is littered with
like airplane hangers basically like big
gigantic warehouse for store ours yeah
the listing for it said it had a garage
for 250 cars and you're gonna get that
goal and I was like
I can't be right and then I towarded the
property you know like a couple weeks
later or something and yeah it had it
has 30 000 square feet of garage yeah
like a man-made lake that that uh he
keeps dying it to to like choose the
color of the lake and like yeah we got
jet skis we have a boat we go
wakeboarding you keep dying it just
because you want the lake blue sometimes
or green or yeah I mean that's a bougie
way to put it I guess but yeah we have
this like
you know it's like there you go I think
she likes me yeah so we have this like
Lake it wraps around the house so the
driveway is this long drive by the
bridge over the water to get to the
house and um yeah I want the water to
look nice so we put dye in it and so
it's like bright blue and pretty but
it's also very healthy for the lake it's
all organic it helps like the sun
penetration for like the algae growth oh
really yeah it's recommended so it's not
as crazy as like people never like hear
about that yeah but yeah lots lots of
lakes have dye in it
you you had just recently purchased this
property in North Carolina at the point
when that when we were there right yeah
super recent so so that I represented
your move from North Virginia to North
Carolina no I was out here actually I
was in um yeah living in Bel Air
of course you are yeah
he's like a young Bruce Wayne dude
he's like you know smart he's he's in
his lab like building things and he's
dead goes on fights crime at night dead
most impressive kid ever dude it's just
so rad yeah what was the first car you
bought when uh when you made your money
like uh you're like I have to have that
or did it just kind of start yeah no we
did so me and my brother started and we
were living at my parents house and uh
we were working on the same channel
together and the first car we bought was
a a Lamborghini
first car you bought was a Lamborghini
yeah the Countach no it was a lime green
Lamborghini Gallardo yeah the Countach
is like uh like an antique like yeah
yeah like some kind of like old 1960s
yeah the green Lamborghini is like fresh
and badass and like you know yeah I went
to this guy's house um he invented the
uh like the ear piercing gun like in the
70s wow and uh he and and he did all
like the do-it-yourself waxing kits in
Walmart in the 80s and like he made his
money and him and Jay Leno are neck and
neck for the the most cars so he would
fly in and be like oh I was I I was
doing recreating a race from the 20s
with the dude I have a Duesenberg and
this other guy had the same Duesenberg
and we recreated a race and so I went to
his house in Malibu and he had a
separate house just for his all of his
cars yeah well that's next level right
there and then and then he has a house
in Manhattan that's another house that
if that it's actually not a house but
the whole front opens up and it's like
he's got Countach like did you see his
Countach he's like which one like 71 72
73 all the years it's wild that's next
yeah I mean I have a few nice cars you
know a couple Lambos and stuff but yeah
not all the cars I collect are super
expensive I buy a lot of just like I try
to buy really interesting cars
do you ever invent something for Market
to get it into the retail space do you
ever think about doing something like
that I have but it's a lot of work
um to do all that so is that something
that would be uh no you just create one
you get a rapid prototyping figure out
how it's made and then you and then you
sell it to a company and I mean your dad
that the hardest part is getting the
patent it would be it would be a father
and son bonding project that you guys
have fun putting together
I mean it would be fun
um like I mean like a back scratcher
that you're just like
or something that like I'm sure you
thought about like I mean constantly
problems to solve right but then again
on the other hand like it almost without
fail if you think of like something that
would be a dope invention and then
Google it like it's been invented it's
fair to say that that's the truth I
think inventing things is really hard
and I don't really think that's like
the best efficient way to like be
successful right you know you don't have
to reinvent the wheel and you know
um this guy went around and he and he
grabbed a guitar pick his whole role is
to go around like Walmart or any stores
and he goes I can change that by 30 so
he got guitar picks he put Mouse ears on
him and sold him to Disney he Pat they
got the light like so he does [ __ ] like
that all day wow oh there's a mop handle
well I can make him off handle that's an
L-shaped and like that's this he's like
he's like the [ __ ] that just puts
an s on the word in the Scrabble what is
that somebody did it's like oh yeah yeah
just add it yeah you know
yeah uh bad analogy
so uh so you your your girl Liz
um also a huge YouTuber also uh part of
the project that that we were working on
which fingers crossed sees the light of
day
um how long have you guys been together
we've known each other since uh since
College
okay so it's been
I don't know probably eight years I
think we met like freshman year wow so
you guys were friends first and then you
got in a relationship yeah we were both
on the swim team so we met like first
week of the first year you know first
semester
and uh yeah just we're kind of close
because of swimming was it loving for a
sight for you uh
uh I don't know my first memory of
seeing her I'm sure it was just like you
know a whole group of people I don't
know you roll up to college yeah
um but yeah we hit it off pretty quick I
mean we were definitely like
we're friends pretty quickly right out
after meeting
you guys swim together now no do you
still swim laps and keep in shape I
don't really swim much no
what was your uh event I did a Sprint
freestyle and Butterfly how far
like as short as possible 50 meters yeah
it'd be like 50 or 100s yeah yeah I used
to play water pole and then I I swam
once and I did one event it was a
thousand meter and I came in dead last a
thousand okay that's a long one it's
[ __ ] the worst yeah that's what Liz
did she was doing like 1650 and the 500.
yeah yeah that's cool Scott and I did a
triathlon together yeah and uh I was
terrified of the swimming and he was
terrified of the bicycle but dude you
actually did better than me and both or
did I
this guy like I'm swimming every day and
I'm and I'm like trying to ride bikes to
keeping it and I can run and dude this
guy smoke me yes I didn't remember that
I beat you in the swimming
maybe you caught up your time on the uh
on the bike but I suck at bike
yeah I do well with with cycling
I enjoy cycling yeah yeah so what do you
what do you do all day
just in general do you have like a
routine
um do you work out do you yeah work out
yeah try to be active
um but yeah most of it is honestly it's
just content content just a lot of
content on the Forefront of your mind
pretty much yeah because I have uh I'm
growing the team trying to build out
like infrastructure I'm trying to build
out like Studio space and office space
um what do you do uh for merchandise is
that a big part of your business yeah
it's not a huge part but it's something
that we do and we're working on growing
that too it just takes a ton and ton of
promotion you just gotta constantly push
it but yeah we have a lot of different
like t-shirts sweatshirts uh we have
like custom plushies
um all that kind of stuff
that's cool man how many people do you
have on your team
uh I have about like ten and those are
all like employees of yours and they all
live on the compound in North Carolina
no but they all live
um around a couple live with me but most
people live
um
you have their own place yeah right
would they say you're an easy going boss
or are you pretty I don't know did you
drive the you know it's a lot of people
to you know like manage and like
coordinate with the content and stuff
but yeah I think it's pretty laid back I
have trouble picturing him like yelling
the way I was earlier yeah but you never
know I mean like like some people have a
passion for what they do and it's like
that's the only thing that matters and
it's like I don't care get your [ __ ]
ass over here you know like right yeah I
think sometimes it could be like that a
little bit yeah yeah I mean I try to
keep it fun because that's kind of the
goal is just to have fun uh but yeah
lots of stress sometimes for sure yeah a
thousand videos
I would say so in how many years I
started like my first ever was probably
uploaded in like 2016.
yeah it's a lot of that's a lot of
videos yeah yeah dude like I uh on my
main Channel
I'm uploading every two weeks right now
and I'm like man dude I should really do
I should just do a video every week I'm
like oh it's so intimidating and that's
one video a week yeah I've kind of been
at one video a week and it's just like
still feels really fast yeah I mean but
people don't realize how busy you
actually are I mean if you told I mean
you probably have a video coming out
soon but like just the last four days
that you've had with Michael that that
flew in yeah I mean that'll be a video
like yeah but I mean he but he was just
like I can't believe how busy you guys
are because you were doing all that
meanwhile there's business to attend to
oh yeah we got podcasts going on you
know it's it's [ __ ] crazy like and
and for me I go back and forth between
being on tour like on my tour bus oh and
by the way did I send you a video of how
I got that motion sensor to work no did
you get it oh damn what a [ __ ] I
am we ordered the thing like on my tour
bus it's uh the bus is wrapped with
Stevo art and so like it kind of draws a
lot of attention and people are banging
on the bus all the time and it gets me
quite a bit so I wanted to get a custom
made light up sign that says it's not
okay to knock please do not disturb and
then uh we we got it and we built in a
light switch but it just didn't make
sense to keep it on all night and I
thought oh my God how rad would it be if
like I had a motion sensor so when
people walk up to the bus like as they
just kind of get close to the door then
the light turns on and says you know to
illuminate it's not okay to knock please
do not disturb it's my first I first
thought just reach out to Carter hey man
can can I get emotions and you sent me
an Amazon link to a motion sensor but it
but uh that one was um it said like not
suitable for uh high temperature like
this is for any indoor setting and we're
like in the middle of like blazing
triple digit whether like uh in
Mississippi in the summertime so I just
went to Home Depot and I got an outdoor
one and wired it through the door and
dude it works brilliantly that's awesome
I love it and then I took it from that
and then I got like a motion sensor
flood lights with camera that kick on
when there's motion on every single
corner of the bus on top of you got it
all locked down there yeah you know it
will still come up candidly I had just
seen
um on TMZ that uh the Machine Gun
Kelly's tour bus got like horribly
vandalized with spray paint and I was
like man I'd really like to have like
flood lights and cameras turn on when
anybody approaches this bus like I'm not
trying to get that kind of treatment
because that happened in like every city
I've not heard of it
um people knocking yeah people not like
vandalizing the bus no I haven't heard
about that yeah but uh people always
knock right where the sign says do not
knock I know were you on the bus when uh
when they're knocking
and now because we've got the the
floodlights with the cameras we can
actually just flip on the app and talk
to them like with the microphone so we
got like it's got a speaker and a
microphone yeah I mean you should put a
sign that says like do not knock or a
thing will come out and hit you in the
face and then be like well you knocked I
know people say the [ __ ] out of you
think about how many people ask me to
kick them in the nuts you don't think
that that would just make a line of
people if I could like knock instead of
something
that would be pretty epic though if you
could just get all those on camera yeah
I mean dude that was another thing the
guy who made the sign I sent him a video
of like how the motion sensor works and
he goes oh dude you should have the
motion sensor set up to a camera and a
fog horn so that when people come in
when they get so close to the door it's
like and then the camera films them like
jumping out of their shoes scared yeah
mace or a taser comes out do you have a
heart out up uh you have to be somewhere
what time he's got a 4 30 meeting as I
understand okay so you're okay we still
have time I thought it was at four yeah
no we're doing pretty good I'm gonna be
so embarrassed of my uh Winnebago Man
screaming about the air conditioner no
we can cut it out I don't care [ __ ] it
dude
you're like
it wasn't it it wasn't flattering it
wasn't how you normally act yeah
if it wasn't how you normally get mad
it was worse hey yeah you're pretty
pissed it wasn't even Vinnie's fault
like I mean it sure it sucked but like
you just took like definitely wasn't
Vinny's fault you just took like seven
different problems and just put it right
on Vinnie like throughout the day so
that's why and he didn't deserve that I
mean if any uh is a ride or die dude I
can call him middle of the night you
know he did he went to San Diego twice
in one day you know what we could do
twice a day yeah and on the way here he
sat in traffic for four hours and then
Steve's like hey we need you to set up
the podcast again he's like dude I'm
there yeah I mean that's
four in the morning you know and and ask
him if he's willing to work right now
and he'll be like dude I'm sorry I was
asleep
bro and he's dedicated to the team and
that's why I want to keep in me looking
like an [ __ ] so I can give Vinnie
love all right cool or maybe we can put
it on Stevo raw
explicit card I do whatever dude that's
awesome I like to be accountable man I'm
generally not a jerk so you know if I if
I acted like one let me let me uh put it
out there
so what's the plan the rest of the day
you're gonna go film some more stuff and
then he's got a top secret meeting for
high level business to make even more
millions of dollars that would be dope
yeah millions of dollars yeah yeah
you're not even denying it I mean that
would be the dream yeah no just meet
with some friends
um but yeah the golf the rest of the day
yeah it's kind of chill after that
probably go to a fancy ass bougie
restaurant
and it takes a [ __ ] Lamborghini
Countach to your private jet here's
here's a question that you don't have to
answer but you've absolutely made over a
million dollars in a single month before
in a single month yeah on ads I mean
what did John end it's a total revenue
like one single day over a million bucks
I don't think so oh no
come on okay it's all about the slow and
steady yeah nice slow and steady I like
that no I don't think I did a million
dollars in a month I know that's where
that's big that's where we need to get
to is we're slow and steady is a million
dollars every month a million dollars
every month yeah that's a good slow and
steady yeah because you're you're very
ad friendly because you've appealed to
like all audiences yeah
the air just went off God damn it hey
I mean it's not Vinny's fault but dude
we might have fun going to Home Depot to
buy a new air conditioner that thing's
done us right for two goddamn years now
we might have fun yeah I get all Amazon
some [ __ ]
yeah do you have an Amazon addiction uh
I ordered a lot of stuff from Amazon
way too much yeah way too much and then
when it shows up you have no idea what
it was so yeah you forget yeah exactly
it's like Christmas that's what a
quality problem to have well yeah
because I spent like
you know over about
half my time on tour and have my time at
home so like when I'm on tour uh it's
just this blistering pace of like you
know show every day and like you know
all the content creation happening
because I've got my my uh editor with me
on the road and like we're doing all
this business and all this like crazy
stuff and then I get to a point where
I'm like oh man I can't wait to go home
and I come home and it's this blistering
pace of everything else like uh it's
gnarly like yeah it seems like you're
crazy busy yeah it's it's pretty intense
life is fun man I wouldn't have it any
other way I uh I I I I fear the day when
I'm not crazy busy yeah I think I thrive
with uh a hectic schedule yeah I don't
think you've ever maybe in the first
year or two like you had down time but
like I don't think so dude since I've
known you we recently went on a vacation
to Hawaii and it drove me nuts you know
what you know it was like five days we
were gone yeah you know what he learned
from his vacation what's that he never
wants to take a vacation another day in
his life that's funny oh yeah I was like
dude relaxing stresses me out like I
literally had the same he was like
what's the point of doing this and I was
like I thought he was just venting and
he's like no seriously what is the point
that we're here yeah we just went like
we just flew and I I hate airports I
hate airplanes and we gotta we went to
an airport to get on an airplane to like
fly all the way to Hawaii so that man
paid for it by the way so that we could
not accomplish but like wait a second
the goal is to not accomplish anything
we're out here like trying to like not
work I think like the idea of radical
self-care you know like just
de-stressing and enjoying life and and
you you got you rescued a dog yeah that
was that that was the best thing we like
we drove past this uh Humane Society
shelter and and and uh the first time I
was like hey let's pull over let's play
with some dogs and and my girl and Scott
I said no and then the second time
there's like nah and then the third time
I talked him into it and uh yeah that's
the thing that people don't realize like
like off camera
that's all you wanted to do was go to
this animal shelter and play with dogs
like that's the real you yeah like that
seemed to made you happy for like the
whole day oh dude that's odd that's all
I wanted to do and then when and then
when we went there it was like oh damn
it we we got a DOT we adopted another
dog you knew it was coming I loved it
they had it set up too so that they um
uh even free of charge would ship the
dog
to the mainland of USA to everyone they
had a whole map at that Humane Society
it was the the Kauai Humane Society they
had a whole wall that was just a map of
America with pins for where they've like
shipped dogs to to forever homes and it
was just littered with pins they're like
yeah we've got it set up with uh like
the air the airline or you know whatever
like so yeah no problem well just just
pick up your dog at the airport when wow
sometimes they can put the dog on the
same flight as they would they would
have except we went over to Maui but
yeah it's rad dude it's rad which uh dog
was that that was Lucy the one that your
girl picked up when we were inside there
oh yeah the black and white dog yeah
that and her name is Lucy lihuey yeah
because we flew into the Lihue Airport
that's awesome look who he is a city in
Kauai when you when you thought you lost
burn this last week oh God the worst but
did you think about how soon can you
rescue another one oh yeah of course
that was the second thought that I'm
already thinking about rescuing another
dog and then who cares if it's the fifth
dog because it's really on my conscience
that Wendy is um
doesn't like the tour bus she doesn't
like the tournaments and I bring her
with me on tour everywhere and I'm like
man what am I what am I doing you know I
should just get another dog that loves
being on the bus
oh wow how are you gonna sleep at night
though
with uh
right I mean but you love sleeping with
Wendy it'll bump me out to not have
Wendy but it bums me out almost more
that like when the bus is driving that
she's like visibly uncomfortable it's
not cool man I don't want to be done I
want to do that to her anymore all right
well how soon are you gonna get a dog
are you gonna get one on the road have
you planned this what do you mean dude
maybe what I'll do
I I was telling Lux like uh that I I was
thinking about going on this next leg
without Wendy this is something we've
got a great guest Carter shared I
haven't looked at him for 12 minutes
sorry dude do you have pets at your
place yeah Liz's got two dogs and five
chickens ah dude chickens any roosters
no
yeah you know I I'm surprised with all
those Acres you don't have like horses
and cows and uh give him a beat he just
moved there yeah I don't think I'm gonna
get animals though
too much work you're gonna have kids
I don't know man that's a that's a big
question I think is it yeah he's 28
years old what are you gonna do
have kids yeah because you're you're uh
you're not gonna get kids I'm snapped
dude that's right I am I'm fully [ __ ]
snapped
I'm down to have kids yeah I think so
I don't get it I I do not understand
what having kids yeah I just don't get
it I think that the world is uh
is slipping man you know like it's uh
like the whole Rich getting richer and
poor getting poorer thing like to create
a person to struggle and and you know
have all the odds against them you know
like it I think like in LA it's like
that like in North he's like dude 111
Acres he's like gets out of his house
he's yawning his Lake's a different
color you know it's like
I think Life's For Us in La life's hard
because we're just on such a [ __ ]
grind and then we're on an hourly grind
there's a lot of homeless everywhere so
it's like getting in your head but did
you lived in Arizona you'd be like you
know [ __ ] the desert's beautiful there's
a lot of space my experience of touring
America on the tour bus is like Stark uh
yeah you know Stark like problems with
Society you know and like opioid
epidemic and you know the meth crisis
and like we'll just don't move to Ohio
yeah but whatever it is man if you want
to have kids then then have at it I
think it'd be a great dad I've been
thinking about it but I don't know and I
think that you and your dad should try
to lock down a patent together get it to
Market I think that that's something
they're good dude it'd be so easy for
you to get it to Market and then you
just or you can just license the idea
and sell it once you have the pattern go
on Shark Tank and then film it and you
got a YouTube video on Shark Tank yeah
just too much though it's too busy make
a video on how to get your product out
of it yeah
I'm getting like a Casey neistat Vibe a
little bit do you like when when uh like
like friends of yours or just people you
know when they reach out and they're
like hey man like let's get together for
dinner or like like let's launch or
something like do you have the thought
like
uh like this like they're asking me to
have a dinner it's kind of not gonna
make good content it's not even gonna be
filming I'm so annoyed that they're
trying to like eat into my day with
something that's not gonna work great on
YouTube like interesting no not really I
mean I keep work work and then I try to
you know do stuff outside but I'm busy
though you know it's not every day I get
to go out to like dinner or fly out to
LA and do stuff out here right so
I think we we think different than
people like dude non-alcohol like he
doesn't yeah such a well-adjusted like
like good [ __ ] kid he's like yeah I'm
at my girl in college we were friends
for a long time
I got to know her you know and I'm just
like right it's just so crazy he's like
no I keep my work separate it's like
dude for us we just have everything's
just yeah it matched together like [ __ ]
dude we're psychos yeah
well right on dude I'm uh like so while
we have the people's attention where
where what are we gonna try to direct it
to
uh your YouTube channel of course oh
YouTube yeah yeah Carter share YouTube
it's all my stuff car to share YouTube
Instagram Tick Tock yeah we got it like
I got to check your Instagram we got to
get that to a million dude we do need to
get that to a million knocking on the
door knocking on the door it's a big
problem 700. no no dude you're you're
creeping up on 900. yeah am I okay
that's good I think it's like 860. I
don't check it very much yeah healthy
boundaries
on Instagram how do you spell share just
so they know
s-h-a-r-e-r okay yeah so follow his
Instagram subscribe to his YouTube yeah
trying to blow everything up yeah that's
the goal yeah and and Liz her and Liz
yeah Lizzy Capri YouTube she's actually
out there filming a video right now in
your backyard
wow which is an absolute disaster like
what have we been hiring Dylan to do the
only thing he does is just throw more
hay on like it's like knee-high deep and
hay the whole [ __ ] Barn have a talk
with Dylan dad
's in deep [ __ ] you're like I gotta talk
to you he's like uh I'm gonna give you a
raise
what's so funny yeah dude all right man
and there's nothing else we want to
drive traffic to that's it yeah all
right dude you're an impressive guy it's
an honor to know you yeah uh I'm
grateful for having you uh join us here
today and um and uh I'm mortified that
we made you push your important meeting
for millions of dollars by a half an
hour yeah it's all good all right dude
thanks man
all right cool just a likable kid man
I'm really rooting for him but then
again you don't even really have to
reform because
he's rich like really rich it's
it's crazy like uh he's one of these
people that makes me think what am I
doing wrong man I work so hard all the
time I'm tirelessly working and like I
just don't have it like that but hey man
it's not about having anything it's
about the grind man I'm addicted to the
grind and I love you guys the street
team here I've been on tour I'm in
Canada right now and uh I've had a few
people introduce themselves to me as hey
dude I'm street team and every time
someone tells me that I hug them I thank
them and it happens a lot during meet
and greets and the meet and greets are
really like have been wearing me down
like it's like dude I love the show and
then the meet and greet like
yeah
but the street team people speaking up
they really
they put Joy back into my my heart my
life and thank you for that all right
guys
[Music]